[Music]
all right so here's how this all got
started I body language is the
management of time space I contact
gesture facial expression stance
movement and what I study is how body
language impacts leadership
effectiveness particularly in things
like managing change negotiation sales
job interviews dealing with
multicultural international teams and I
also blog for Forbes and that's what I
blog on I blog on mostly on body
language and leadership but last April I
did a blog on 12 ways to spot a liar at
work now my blogs do you know you never
know some blogs get a couple thousand if
it's really popular over time it'll get
to twenty thirty maybe eighty thousand
this blog and the first ten days got two
hundred and sixty three thousand hits
and I thought well okay people are
interested in that topic as was I and
also I thought it would be easy as here
I was practically an expert already I
mean I had I had done a lot of research
on nonverbal cues and and lying I was
interested in topic and I thought it'll
be easy to write the book and what I
found was I knew so little first of all
I didn't know what a big liar I was but
secondly I found out many many things
and that's what I'm gonna talk to you
about a few of them today first of all
you work with a bunch of liars and they
lie for a bunch of reasons one of the
things that I did was interview 547
people in the workplace to find out what
kind of Lies they were experiencing on a
regular basis and I found there was the
you know from all levels chief executive
officers and senior leaders
you know gave sort of a rose-colored
version of the truth which by the way
isn't looked at as Oh what we understand
that's what you have to do it's looked
at as those people are lying to us from
co-workers who lie about
yes I'll work on your team when they
really don't want to work on your team
and they're really not going to really
participate but they just had to say
that to all sorts of reasons that are
very either self-serving
a lot of people lied to get out of
things they don't want to do a lot of
people told me they lied to get out of
meetings no no I have something else I
need to do we're really I just don't
want to go to your meeting they lie on
resumes they lie and they enhance you
know their ability they got a degree
that they really didn't get a degree
they went to the school they really
didn't go to that school they had so
many years in the workplace that they
embellish that we're really working you
know for their mom or something I mean
if they just embellished that they also
lie on exit interviews they particularly
lie in exit interviews when think it's
better for their career I've had many
people say if I told the truth about why
I'm leaving this company it would be a
career killer so they live in the time
they get hired to the time they leave
they also people also lie of course to
avoid punishment they lie to get out of
things
like I say that they don't want to do
and they you know lie to cover their
rear end they didn't do something and
they lie about it in order so people
don't find out that they didn't do that
something they also lie to protect other
people and here was the first thing that
you find out in gender differences well
everybody lies and everybody lies about
the same amount females tend to lie a
little bit more to protect other people
and that's not always a great thing one
of my many of mine but one I remember in
particular said you know something it's
really bad when I'm trying to give
feedback because I try not to hurt their
feelings so I'm not giving really honest
feedback now what does that it even that
woman said and I'm working on that I'm
trying to get better at that but I know
it's really hard for me to
so women more than men in my study
anyway will lie to kind of protect
someone which again may not be a great
thing to do and a lot of Liars of course
lie because it is the social glue that
holds any kind of organization or family
or relationship together if you ask me
how I am you really don't know or you
really don't want to know how my entire
day went what you want me to say is oh
I'm fine how are you that's what we
expect so we know we're set up for some
kind of lies some of the lies are
wonderful you might say gee Carol that's
a nice jacket and I'll say great good
thing they didn't notice the five pounds
I gained over Mother's Day you know I
mean so it's lying by that kind of
omission those are the kind of liars you
want to thank so we're surrounded by
liars some lies are really great for
business and really great for
relationships and some lies are
absolutely damaging and destructive and
one of the big tricks is to weed out one
kind from the other so here's a question
for you how do you decide if someone you
work with is trustworthy how do you do
it how do you decide somebody go to
school with who's trustworthy what do
you do how do you know
so you you trust initially and then you
wait for some action
okay in the back the old a trust by
starting with something small and
they'll build it up so you build trust
by you see if they're trustworthy in
smaller situations and then you give
them more information or more of your
trust as they look like they deserve it
how else yeah yeah you ask someone else
what have you heard about what what
don't I know
that I should a little bit but the way
someone establishes eye contact anything
else yes so you break up with them
before you date then you see how you put
someone in emotional stress to see how
they reacted that you know this is what
audiences tell me all the time that
Trust is something that grows that has
to be built that you look for certain
things I want to show you how you really
decide whom to trust this is research
from Princeton what they have done and
I'll show you I'm gonna show you the
little movie of it as they say if you
move three things on a face eyebrows
cheeks and chin you can make a person
trustworthy or untrustworthy and that we
decide if someone's trustworthy in about
the first seven seconds of meeting them
like we make all these other assumptions
about people are they attractive are
they someone we want to be with are they
likable all of that in the first seven
seconds so if the inner corners of your
eyebrows are high if your cheekbones are
prominent and if your chin is wide you
look trustworthy instantly if your inner
corners of your eyebrows are low if your
cheekbones are recessed
and if your chin is narrower we don't
trust you they've also done one other
thing in this little clip and that is
they've taken the corners of the mouth
from up to down neutral trustworthy
untrustworthy yeah yeah the shading so
that's how quick it is that's how fast
we make a decision about other people
biases prejudices assumptions are also
right in our way when we go to find out
if someone is trustworthy or if they're
telling the truth they interfere
amazingly if you are working with
someone who is attractive whose eyebrows
are in the right place who is powerful
who is charismatic or who somehow remind
you of yourself you tend to focus so
much on those attractive qualities that
you don't know you're being duped
that's exactly how it works here's some
more biases that interfere with
deception detection one is that in-group
out-group bias this is so strong we
create in groups out of everybody that's
here is an in-group those people that
didn't get to hear this lecture they're
in our group of course what they see the
tape then maybe they're an in-group but
right now there's us and there's them
and we us and them all the time we tend
to trust people in an in-group much more
than we trust people that are dissimilar
or in an out group and we do it
automatically in fact when you look at
cross-cultural lie detection we actually
process what's being said by ourselves
and what's being said by people from our
in-group differently with a different
part of the brain then we process things
that are being said by people in that
out group
it's a very strong bias what I call
vested interest bias this is why you
know we should be the best at knowing if
our spouses if our loved ones if the
people we're dating if our best friends
are liars and many times were the worst
because we have a vested interest in
their telling us the truth if your
boyfriend or girlfriend says I love you
we have an interest in having that be
true if our child says you know no I
didn't do that I wasn't one of those
people that got caught doing that I
wasn't even there we have a vested
interest in having that child because we
raised that kid so that kids got to be
pretty good anytime you have a vested
interest in someone you are biased
toward them being truthful appropriate
behavior bias is an interesting one and
that is I know or I think I do
how I'd act if I were telling the truth
so when I see someone who is acting
differently they got to be lying you see
it's just like grief people don't grieve
the same some people you know go into a
manic kind of high and some people go
into an incredible depression and some
people are somewhere in between but
we're not the same it's the same way
with lying it's not totally identical
plus we don't really know how we look
when we're telling a lie we just assumed
we would look a certain way we do this
all the time when we're watching people
on television he must be lying because
look at the way he did something I would
never do that and confirmation bias this
is the most insidious of all let me show
you how your brain works I was raised in
Palo Alto when I graduated from poly
high my first job was a night job at
that time we had been living on Oregon
Avenue and in our into you know the
wisdom of my entire family and financial
deals we sold that house because we made
I don't know three thousand dollars or
something so
obviously that was a great deal so my
parents then moved and they were living
in and managing this condominium complex
now these are the kind of condominiums
that are all alike in a row I'm working
nights I come home it's like 3:00 in the
morning I'm tired and I walk up to the
condominium have my key out and I
noticed there's a bicycle and I thought
well we don't have a bicycle okay my dad
also was in the he did a lot of things
but he also was uh doing some work with
newspapers maybe for some of the news
boys or somebody he had you see got a
bicycle for a prize I don't know I walk
in I go hmm all new furniture now
instead of my brain going wrong wrong my
brain does what every brain does and
that is tries to make sense of something
I know it's true I know I'm in my
parents house therefore this furniture
can be explained okay they went out and
bought it tonight I mean I did this
entire muscle turn you know it probably
only took a few seconds it felt like
about five minutes they're trying to
rationalize what was going on I looked
over and the door to the lower bedroom
was open his condominium had three
bedrooms two were upstairs one was below
and my uncle was staying with us and I
said he would never leave the door open
it was only then that I realized it's
3:00 in the morning and I'm standing in
some stranger's condominium now my
parents being the managers had the
master key I could have walked into any
of them but that's how brains work once
you've decided you know the truth once
you've seen those eyebrows go down so
you know that you don't like that person
you don't even know why you don't like
that person or he reminds you of
somebody you don't like once you've made
that decision then you are going to
think and look for all the ways that
justify that decision aha I knew I
couldn't trust him and and you will find
and give much more meaning if somebody
does this and you like him you know oh
that's the way she stands I've seen to
do that a lot of times if someone does
this you don't like I'm a hawk resistant
I knew it see I can't trust
person we will read into it once we've
made up our mind all right
the verbal and nonverbal signs of
deception this was the most fun to do
well do some verbal first selective
wording I want you to ask me if I've
ever taken drugs did I answer the
question no no ask me did I leave my
last workplace under good conditions
things that I you know we're more in
line with my skills and talents did I
answer the question no selective wording
quasi denials that's like I could be
wrong but this is what I think happened
or I'm not absolutely sure but it's
probably something like this you've
already back out of a statement that
you're gonna make so quasi denials many
times Liars will use qualifiers to the
best of my knowledge I could be wrong
again also it could be instead of on
that quasi denial instead of asked me if
I stole the computer I look like someone
who would steal computers did I answer
your question no see
anytime you deflect and move around by
selectively wording quasi denying
qualifying you're getting some slippery
or you may be getting some slippery
answers softeners when someone is being
asked about a potential crime or a theft
forgery they will use when they answer
question
they'll use words like steel forge hard
words if someone is guilty of that and
they're being asked they will typically
soften and talk about things like borrow
or a mistake overlooked they will soften
the language around the the crime or the
or the situation overly formal wording I
did not have sexual relationship with
that woman miss Lewinsky not I didn't
have sex with Monica you know I did not
have to so the first thing to look for
is if they don't use contractions if
it's did not
instead of didn't that's overly formal
and when they tried a distance that
woman she's over there somewhere I have
no idea where she is
that woman miss Lewinsky overly formal
the other thing to remember is sometimes
people actually do tell you the literal
truth but you don't hear it that way so
remember if your boss says I'm thinking
of putting you up for that new job
that's opening in someone else's
department that's exactly what she means
she's not putting you up she may not put
you up but she's thinking about putting
you up so don't hear more into words
than what people say people will
typically tell you the truth but they'll
put it in a way that you can read a lot
of things into that nonverbal here's the
science behind detecting lies
non-verbally most people if we're not
habitual or pathological or practiced or
any of those other things when we lie
our brains have to work harder first of
all we have to remember the truth then
we have to construct the lie we have
remember not to tell the truth we have
to remember how how we might answer some
questions around the lie we have to
remember to whom we told the lie I mean
it is it's so stressful that for big
lies most of us would much rather tell
the truth it's just a lot easier you
don't have to remember who you said what
to it's just simpler so when we lie
there's some stress our heart rates go
up blood pressure goes up breathing
rates get shallow and those are the
things that you start to see in body
language so much of detection of lies is
really stress detection which means by
the way that you can't say when you see
some of these oh that person's lying
what you can say is we've hit a hot spot
something in this question something in
this line of questioning something that
just happened someone who just came into
the room triggered something because
they are acting stressed so stress
signals or anything typically things
like playing with your do where you see
people that are nervous start to twirl
their rings they may rub their hands
together remember their hands on their
legs they may bounce their feet you also
can do all these things for other
reasons but when you see this at a
certain time it can be very telling feet
by the way are incredibly honest so the
most honest part of your body cuz of the
farthest from your brain and the least
rehearsed so when somebody is really
nervous you can see them wrap their feet
around their you know the back of the
chair you can see them do all sorts of
very fascinating things with their feet
you can also things start to point
toward the door they really wish this
line of questioning we're over and
they're ready to go
I mean there's a lot of things that
happen that you can see also feet can
point towards you you know so if for
instance you're really engaged what I'm
saying your feet more likely point
toward me if you're not so engaged they
start pointing other places same way in
a group you can tell who really people
are interested in because their feet
start to point at them they may be still
talking though they're folks but their
feet are pointed at the leader or the
boss or the most charismatic or or
whomever so feet are a lot of fun too
in stress when you think of stress you
think of fight-or-flight but actually
the first sign of stress is what
physiologically freeze everybody freezes
so many times what you're looking for is
not the fight-or-flight stuff the
bounciness or the trying to get out of
the room you're looking for all of a
sudden people get very still they start
to freeze if they were animated before
and their gestures stop or they hide
their hands under the table or you can
almost see it in their breathing they
hold their breath I mean there are lots
of things that people do when they
freeze that doesn't look like their
normal behavior the most important thing
of course is to find behaviors that are
a deviation from their truth baseline
now here's how that works I'm coming in
for a job interview so before the
interview you offer me a cup of coffee
so while you're all you don't care if I
drink the coffee or not what you want to
see is we're having this chit chat is
how you know how I gesture how I talk
what my tone of voice is under stress
our forces get higher so you want to see
if our my you know how are my voice is
when I'm just chatting about things then
you do something way before the
interview starts and that is you ask me
questions to which you know the answer
so you say because it's down in your
notes you arty know this but you say hey
do you how did you hear about this job
opening you watch me as I answer because
it I have no reason to lie about that
you can tell you already know the answer
to it do you have any friends that work
here you already know that cuz it's
written down to people in the
organization referred me you again
you're looking for a baseline but you're
looking for a baseline of truthful
answers because tapping feet if my feet
are tapping I'm saying oh yeah I know a
lot of people here then it's not gonna
mean anything if you're gonna use it as
a cue to deceit but if I'm very calm and
I change my behavior when you ask me a
question about why I left my last job
and it's different from that truth
baseline then then you might again you
might have a hot spot
tell tale for what you want to do is
look for clusters now they can be
clusters of verbal and nonverbal so
let's say you are interviewing me again
and you have asked me about why I left
my last job and I've been evasive and
you're writing notes but all of a sudden
you hear that my voice got higher so
that got your attention and you and you
looked up because you know that when
voices get higher that means stress and
then you see that I'm touching either my
necklace or my neck and because I'm a
woman women tend to when they're
stressed or surprised or thrilled they
tend to to touch right here the notch at
their neck or they play with jewelry
that's close to it just like you did we
we do that so if all of a sudden my
voice got your attention because it was
higher and then you notice another
stress signal and then there was
something in that answer that I said you
know I've left to pursue other thing I
didn't really answer your questions now
you have a cluster of behaviors and what
you might do with that cluster of
behaviors is absolutely nothing you
might not say hey I noticed you touched
your neck and your voice would you know
you might not do that you might just
kind of put a little asterisk at that
question and go on to some other
questions you'd notice that if my hand
dropped and my voice got lower and I got
I seem to be more animated and and then
you might go back to say if I called
your last boss what would he tell me
about you and then again you'd notice
because if you now you're getting those
reactions twice there's something about
that situation that I haven't been
forthcoming so that's how you would
would use these the tell-tale four is
out of Northeastern University and they
they did this study and no one else has
replicated it but I'm just throwing it
out to you that there are four body
language cues that if you see them in
the course of say two three four minute
conversation this is the telltale
cluster this means you're talking to a
liar so if they touch their face if they
rub their hands together
if they pull back and if they cross
their arms if you get those four you got
a liar according to this research so
you'll have to tell me you'll have to be
my study group and and see if that's
accurate or not I signals the biggest
myths around deception is that Liars
don't look you in the eye and partly
children don't aren't real good at
looking in the eye kids are you know a
lot like more likely to drop their eye
contact but so are people from different
cultures you know so are people I mean
there's many many reasons why someone
would drop their eyes which is good to
know by the way when we when we end up
with this about how not to look like a
liar so I'll go back to that in a minute
but right now just know that there's no
research that says that Liars don't look
you in the eyes in fact good Liars or
maybe not so good Liars actually
overcompensate because they've heard
that too so they look you too much in
the eyes and pretty soon you think why
didn't he just stop looking at me or
she's just staring at me as this is
getting creepy and because I'm trying to
make sure that you know that I'm telling
the truth
but there are some eye signals that
actually are valid another one that
isn't valid by the way is the neuro
linguistic programming NLP work about if
you look up to the right it means
something if you look up to the left it
means something there it probably does
mean something I'm not saying that it's
incorrect with that but there's no
correlation to where your eye moves and
if you're lying or not I was taught that
I was taught that if your eyes moved to
a certain direction it meant you were
constructing a truth rather than
recalling a truth but studies now say
not so much what is true though because
I've tested this on my sister is if you
know where people with eyes go when they
are answered in their truth baseline
when you say you have you know I know
you know a couple people who work here
who are they and you see them oh yeah it
was Francis and then Jacob and you
notice where their eyes go and then you
ask them something later and their eyes
go to the other side as if they're
getting information from another part of
their brain that would be telling
regardless of which side their
go to the other thing that happens in
lying is that your eyes dilate now there
are lot of places your eyes dilate
dilates in darkness dilates when you're
in love with someone and you're gazing
at each other's eyes your eyes are both
dilated check that out everyone yep but
also again that effort of lying cells
here and this is very confusing because
if you're in love with someone in your
eyes dilate but if you're lying to them
saying I'm in love with you their eyes
will also dilate so maybe this isn't a
good cue for that use it for something
else so eyes do dilate under the strain
of having to create the lie and then
there's a blink rate when the liar is
lying the blink rate goes down the
minute the lie is after it's constructed
and told the blink rate is low and after
the lie is told oftentimes Liars blink
rate will increase up to eight times now
blink rate makes people look nervous
I know when I was doing some of the
washings of the presidential campaigns
high blink rates they're not good for a
presidential candidate because it makes
them look like they're lying or unsure
but literally if they're blink rate is
low and then it goes up to ever they've
said something that would be a better
indicator than just normal blink rate
and emotional in congruence this is
where I think a lot of people who are
good at detecting lies fine it's kind of
that gut feeling you get when something
is off and that could be because you
don't know it but you're really pretty
good at spotting micro-expressions those
expressions that hit for a fraction of a
second and then get caught immediately
and replaced usually with a phony smile
which is our favorite replacement sign
for anything we don't want people to see
any other emotion when something is off
when something with their body language
is off when someone says like a an
executive that I saw speak was asking
for questions and he said now I'm open
for questions I mean
there's something I mean you and I
laughed that entire audience not one
person caught that but they couldn't
come up with any questions it was such a
dichotomy between what he was saying and
what his body was displaying so those
are the things that you catch
unconsciously or consciously now more
more often and that will make you think
somebody's lying so you wanna that's
that gut feeling you want to pay
attention to it
there is something though that emotions
won't tell you a liar can look
incredibly fearful that he's gonna be
caught but so can a truthful person look
very fearful that you're not gonna
believe him so fear you're not
mind-reading what you're doing is
picking up any motion and you can be
pretty good at that
you can say okay I know that's fear but
you cannot say what generated that fear
liars you when it comes to the chapter
that I wrote on how to deal with Liars
really interesting stuff because you got
a lot of choices you can report a liar
you can confront a liar you can ignore a
liar or you can thank a liar you know
thank the one that tells you how good
you look when you really don't feel that
good but here are the questions see and
unlike other things I can't give you the
five things to do but I can give you the
few questions to ask so you can build
your own strategy because it really
depends first of all it depends on your
legal obligation when you go into the
workplace or the classroom if you're
teaching you're gonna have some legal
obligations you are going to have to
report pornography even your own no I'm
kidding I'm kidding you have to report
pornography you're going to have to
report child abuse you're going to have
to report certain sexual abuses I mean
those things are mandated and there's no
getting out of that those things you
have to report you don't have you can't
ignore them you can't ignore them
legally you can't ignore them
ethically or morally you're also going
to be in an organization that has
certain policies for reporting and
you're gonna have to know what those
policies are and follow them because if
particularly if you want to report
someone and you don't follow procedure
and you do something else it's it's
gonna come back and hit you in the face
not them
it'll be why didn't you do it the right
way you were you weren't supposed to go
to your boss's boss you were supposed to
go to HR you were what or whatever so
you want to make sure you know how that
how that works it also depends on who
the liar is if the liar someone you're
negotiating with you're gonna respond to
that maybe very differently than if the
liar is your boss or if the liar is
someone who reports to you or if the
liar is one of your co-workers a
colleague a friend it depends on what
the impact of the lie is and if you're
going to report Liars by the way this is
what you need to document you can't go
into HR or your boss or your boss's boss
or to whomever and say my feelings were
really hurt when this person lied to me
I am so upset they don't really care but
you could go in and say this lie is
damaging team morale you need to give
them some impact on the team or the
organization or the project
something that makes some kind of not
only personal you can certainly say how
it's affecting you personally but the
more you can document the impact of the
lie in a bigger arena the better it is
and this is very interesting what do you
want the liar to do do you want her to
resign do you want her to be fired do
you just want her to know that you know
do you want her simply to go somewhere
else because you know she's a big liar
and you never want to work with her
again but you just don't even want her
to even know that you know do you want
her to apologize do you want her to
retract the lie what is it that you want
and depending on those answers
it's gonna be different and then when
you figure that out you need to think
what are the possible consequences of
doing all of these things when you
report a liar you may or may not get the
reaction you were hoping for that liar
may not be fired that liar you may be
moved to another division I've seen this
happen you know I mean you just don't
know what what the outcome is you need
to really think that through
if the liar is someone who is well
respected in the organization and you're
new to the company you're gonna have to
really have a lot of evidence before
anything you say is going to outweigh
that person's reputation directly
confronting has some impact that you
might not want if you have to work with
that person on an ongoing basis you
might want to have not have a direct
confrontation you might want to do
something a little more indirect there
are a lot of ways to do that as well and
of course doing nothing has its own
implications doing nothing by the way
does not mean that you forgive the liar
it simply means you've chosen not to
deal with it at this time and many times
someone says I did nothing but I will
never ever ever trust that person again
okay and the last piece I want to talk
about just briefly is how not to look
like a liar when you're telling the
truth two things number one is if most
people realize and are picking up on
stress cues you need to manage your
stress if you go into a job interview
and you're just nervous
you're gonna look nervous but you also
may look that you're like you're not
forthcoming or you're not entirely
candid so what you want to do is
decrease your cortisol level your stress
hormone level and increase your
testosterone which is your power hormone
and you can do that in two ways one is
that two-minute exercise called power
poses and
obviously do this in the men's or ladies
room before the interview by the way you
do not walk in and do this at the
interview but where you take up as much
room as you possibly can and you hold
that pose
for two minutes doing that literally
increases the amount of testosterone you
are more likely to take risks you walk
in you keep more of that in your posture
as you walk in and you are perceived as
more powerful and more comfortable
because you have also lowered that
cortisol level simply by holding your
body and a high power pose for two
minutes so power posing is one way power
thinking is another way and what they
found is it doesn't take much but right
before that interview be very careful
about what you're thinking because if
you will I always tell people keep a
success log let's say you just bombed in
another interview and now you got to go
to this one you better have a way to
drop this fast
and remind yourself of how to riff 'ok
you are so just by reading or mentally
reviewing times when you just aced it
when you were brilliant and clever and
wonderful you will go in there and you
will actually behave differently and
they can quantify that it doesn't take
much time at all in fact that's what
method actors do they go back into time
to find a place where they were
emotionally valid frightened if they're
gonna do a scary scene so they can take
that emotion of fear authentic emotion
of fear into that new scene so it's
something actors do all the time but
it's amazing now the research they've
done and it's particularly good for job
interviews so remember those two things
power pose and that power thinking kind
of thing and by the way when you are in
the waiting room what you don't want to
do is bring your smartphone because what
does your body do it hunches over it
does this what you have done now is
you've decreased your testosterone and
increased your stress hormones
cortisol level bring a newspaper you
know stretch so your hands can actually
stretch out I mean it there is something
to this so make it work in your favor
and of course the other thing is since
most people believe that eye contact is
important even if it's not in your
cultural heritage to have that kind of
eye extended eye contact I don't not
stalker stare we're not going there
we're simply talking about you know
looking at someone maybe 60% of the time
particularly when they're talking so
that you make that connection
you will simply look more candid now I
want to tell you one quick story and I
won't probably have time for questions
so what do you want a story your
questions I can do either because we
have five minutes alright I was asked
this last year I was asked to go to
North Dakota and work with the
Department of Commerce work with the
leadership team at the Department of
Commerce so I went back there and I met
Tracy and Tracy said you know I attended
another speech that you gave and only
because of that can I tell you this
story she said I am very truthful I
pride myself on my truthfulness and my
candor and my ability to build trust in
a team so when my organization my
leadership team said we're going to do a
trust survey I was I was the first to
sign up and then I got the results and
two of the people I report to said the
same thing you look like you have a
hidden agenda you look like you're not
totally forthcoming it seems as if
you're holding things back well you can
imagine I mean Tracy was devastated so
she thought as most people will okay
I'll meet with those leaders and I'll
find out what I can do differently so
she had a meeting and they said all
right here's what we suggest
before you present an idea maybe you
need to give us more the backstory so it
doesn't look like there's something so
self-serving here's what I've been
thinking about here's why I decided this
idea would be good for the organization
months and months
Tracy worked on this backstory did the
whole thing present her ideas next year
trust survey same results
you don't look candid you're not telling
us the whole thing that looks like I
have a hidden agenda and she said then I
heard you speak and I thought could it
be something I'm doing with my body so
she thought she said you know we're in
North Dakota it's pretty cold here in
the winter you know I called but because
I'm going back there in the fall to do
another thing for the Governor's
Conference but I I called them they tell
me the high today is 12 below I mean you
know that's cold to me so anyway she
said it's pretty cold here and she said
and I'm naturally cold anyway so I would
sit in the meetings and I would I would
kind of huddle up cross my arms and and
it pulled my body in and she said so I
wondered if if I didn't do that if I
would come across differently so she
said so I layered you know I was born
like five sweaters and but I was
comfortable and she said so I uncross my
arms I would gesture with my hands
showing more sweeping gestures more
inclusive warmer kind of looks and that
was it the next trust survey highly
trustworthy very candid I mean it was
amazing when people talk to me about
impression management and they say well
Carol if you're telling us in an
interview you know you stand like this
before you go in and you you know you
you you have to layer in a cold room I
mean isn't that just kind of lying is
that kind of manipulative and I say yeah
sure it's just as manipulative as a
spell checking your resume before you
send it in or dressing for success
before you go on that or minding your
manners you know if you're going out for
a business lunch all of those very
manipulative and highly recommended by
the way
body language is when you're working on
impression management it's not to fool
people that you're something you're not
cuz you really are smart you really are
good you really are talented and you
really are candid so why don't you just
look that way all right that's it thank
you so much really great
[Music]